my name is susan alcantara and this
webinar we will discuss the basics of
lifestyle analysis applies
applied specifically to the neuroscience
research field
i will illustrate different concepts
using relevant examples that you can
hopefully find useful for your own
research
i really hope that you find the next 25
minutes interesting and useful
the last few decades have seen a large
number of failed clinical trials in the
leadershine field
therefore whilst this area has great
potential is now regarded as higher risk
the main challenges i believe that
neuroscience research encountered as the
extraordinary complexity of the human
brain and its plasticity
making it difficult to model in the lab
the difficulty of accessing human tissue
and the ethics behind it
the questionable translational value of
animal research models
as you know we are still identifying
neurons in human which are not being
previously seen in rodent brain
and finally the extreme sensitivity that
characterizes neuronal culture
now having said that the field of
neuroscience has also witnessed
remarkable developments in more recent
times
and there is an increased investment
towards this research area once again
an important advance for example is the
development of human ipscs which
presents a huge potential to generate
fully humanized
patient-specific advanced cell model
when coupled to more advanced techniques
one can help
yield better translation to the clinic
there are currently a great number of
possible cell-based strategies to model
a particular disease
from immortalized cell lines to more
advanced cell types such as
patient-derived ipscs and from 2d
up to organelles while cell lines and 2d
cultures
still provide valuable basic information
the increased complexity of advanced
systems i believe can potentially lead
to an increased translation to the
clinic
these advanced cell systems are composed
of pressure cells due to limited supply
or higher costs
they provide more dynamic systems with
increased plasticity
which is studied using the right
technology and appropriate analytical
methods can be information rich
therefore translating into much relevant
disease information
now for this reason we need to develop
cell spelling workflows which allow us
for temporal monitoring and relevant
non-perturbing analytical methods
the common technologies currently used
in the neuroscience field are capable of
measuring various aspects of cell health
morphology and function but we need to
take into consideration
firstly that multiple pieces of
equipment are necessary to answer the
bad questions
and secondly that to move science
forward faster one need approaches that
are information rich and can track
dynamic biological processes as they
unfold
one of the aims of this webinar is to
show you how well-suited life cell
analysis in the development and
validation of advanced
models so firstly what is life cell
analysis
it is a continuous or semi-continuous
cellular measurement
and it needs to provide relevant
information in real time
it certainly needs to be obtained from
living cells and the data acquisition
should be non-perturbant to these cells
a direct consequence of this is that
these measurements are non-exhaustive
meaning that
once the ass is finished these cultures
can still be used for secondary
downstream
endpoint analysis if necessary now
lastly it needs to be applicable
across workflows so that ideally a
single instrument is flexible enough to
answer multiple questions on morphology
health function and dynamism
and can provide information during all
research phases not only the
sfa we have here the comparison of
traditional
endpoint workflow with data flight cell
analysis the only analytical data
generated by the end point approach is a
single and arbitrary time point obtained
during the sfa
in contrast lex cell analysis offers
continued information during culture
manipulation
and finally the kinetic assay
so how do we go about creating a
technology capable of truly performing
lifestyle analysis on those terms
described before
well the data i'm about to show you has
been acquired using the inquisite light
cell analysis system which is a platform
an integrated solution of hardware
software reagents and applications
all designed to work together the
hardware is a microscope optimized to
permanently reside in the standard lab
incubator
it takes images from cells culture in
different types of vessels like flasks
plates petri dishes etc the software
restores and analyzes the images to
extract phenotypic data in real time
and all this comes with reagents and
applications which have been optimized
by the rnd teams to which i belong for
the youth in this system
in this webinar i will cover four major
research areas and i will provide you
with relevant examples which will show
you
how one can automatically quantify the
cell health of your culture
the neurodynamics and neuronal activity
as well as the near immune function
all this is in lifestyle non-perturbing
real-time analysis in the way described
before
let's start introducing the first area
neuronal cell health
in this first example i will show you
the use of an xin5 to understand cell
death of your culture
this reagent as you know binds to
exposed phosphatidylserine which is one
of the hallmarks of cell death
it releases a fluorescent signal which
increases with death
so briefly cells are seated and treated
with drugs diluted in media supplemented
with an exim 5 reagent
images are taken for the necessary
amount of time and automatically analyze
you can see the onset of this in the
images below
this experiment has been performed in
collaboration with cdi
high glutamines and monoculture were
plated in 96 well plates and culture for
10 days
after this time they were treated with
increasing concentrations of glutamate
alone or in combination with the nmda
antagonist mk801
all these in the presence of an exim 54
and 3 agent
cell death was recorded for the father
72 hour the greatest asset window was
reached within the first 24 hours post
treatment time at which the crc graph
was derived
now a different visualization of this
experiment is represented with the plate
view on the right hand side
in which each square represents a well
and within it you can see the temporal
response of an xm5 orange intensity
signal
the next research area i wanted to
discuss today is the ability to
quantitatively measure neurodynamics in
monoculture in a non-perturbing and
non-exhaustive way
we call this the neurotrack application
neurons are plated
treated if necessary image and neural
can cell bodies are analyzed in real
time and automatically segmented
you can see the masks in yellow and blue
respectively
this method obviates the needs the need
to fix and stain in order to obtain
neurotograph reading saving time
decreasing experimental artifacts and
enabling the visualization of plasticity
these assets perform levels level free
and the sensitivity is such that one can
obtain differential profiles in the
development of networks from for
instance
different primary brain regions in the
example on the
shown on the right hand side of your
screen one can compare the speed of
development of cortical
stretching hippocampal and midbrain
neuronal networks
the type of data that we may be able to
study using the neural track application
is for example the non-perturbant
differentiation of cell lines or
neuroprogenitor cells
as in this example on the left of your
screen in which the video and its
temporal analysis represents the process
of differentiation
of human ipa cd5 neurons obtained via
collaboration with axle bioscience
this can be applied for example for qcn
proposes or workflow optimization
another application that maybe may be
able and compound profiling for example
during drug discovery project
again i would like to stress that those
cells have not been perturbed in any way
so that by the end of this experiment
they can
still be used for downstream secondary
endpoint measurements if necessary
now this application is amenable to
monoculture only when a base of cells
exists as with the study of
neurodynamics in cocals the introduction
of a fluorescent marker is required
as face contrasting images alone are not
able to discriminate the neuronal
projections from the background of
support
cells as you can imagine
for this reason and we have developed
the neurolite orange reagent which is a
length divider that encodes a
fluorescent protein
this protein is driven of a synapsing
promoter to strengthen neuronal
expression and minimize the neuronal
crossover
with this reagent we can enable labeling
that is neuronal specific
long-lasting and non-detrimental to cell
health
here we show a kinetic adaptation of the
well-known model as x-hd a model of
neurodegeneration in parkinson's disease
primary cortical neurons and astrocytes
were co-cultured and infected with
neural light
we then waited for 14 days until we
observed that nira developed was
established
then the cochlea was treated with
various concentrations of the neurotoxin
60hda readily used to kill neurons in
this model
neuronal growth measurements continue
for for 10 more days
and now we're moving on to the third
research area the neuronal activity now
during this webinar i especially wanted
to touch on this new application with
check launch
which i believe is of great value and
has the potential to enlighten us with
important insights on the biology of our
neuronal cultures
i will try to convince you about this
within the next few slides as i
mentioned before the inquisite is an
integrated solution composed of reagents
optimized protocols software and
hardware and this application i'm about
to introduce you represents an example
of this
the neutron activity application uses a
new reagent the neurobiosaurons which is
a genetically encoded calcium indicator
in the presence of calcium calmodulin
undergoes a conformational change and
forms a complex
which then emits light this reagent
enables the functional study of actively
fighting neurons by reporting calcium
oscillations that can be seen and
measured in the urine channel
the protocol is a simple antiviral
infection of your co-cultures with
neurobus
if necessary one can let the network
stabilize before adding the required
treatment
imaging of these calculus can start at
any stage during this process
in order to see and measure the calcium
oscillations we've developed a new
acquisition mode
what we call as the stair mode which
takes images at high frequency during up
to three minutes
the video here shows you the
three-minute epoch of highly
synchronized high glutathiones from cdi
co-culture with rap primary astro
science
the software automatically segments
these high frequency images so one gets
the information in real time
just to add the nearest orange is
compatible with a variety of neuronal
cell types it's non-perturbant and it
maintains expression over weeks or
months
in summary this application enables the
long-term monitoring of neuronal
excitability and network
and network activity in coculture
we see here the type of data obtained
with this module the image is a collage
of single well-ceiling phase to
qualitatively assess cell health orange
which give us information on areas with
calcium influx and its segmentation
indicating the presence of active
bursting nodes the increased software
automatically calculates an inactivity
plot summarizing the changing activity
of each pixel
during the three minutes epoch each
individual carcinoma oscillation from
each active node within the forex
field of view is recorded and
represented in the superimposed calcium
trace
as the one you can see above where each
line represents a node
for a seat of 25 thousand cells per well
for example we normally achieve a brown
and southern active
nodes plating density can be optimized
by the researchers for their particular
experimental needs
now if we repeat the measurement every
24 hours and of course this can also be
modified based on research needs
we can follow the development of network
its connectivity and stability as seen
in the middle bottom figure enabling the
study of plasticity for example
the 96 well plate views on the right
represent the calcium summary trace
in each well at a single time on the top
or the concatenation of metrics in the
bottom
to provide a long-term picture of
activity this enables the study of for
example slow modulation during long-term
neurodegeneration
before i continue with the translational
example of this technique i would like
to show you some validation we are all
used to seeing
in this slide we will show you how one
can modulate neuronal fighting activity
by using drugs such as the stimulant
antagonist pictotoxin or the potent
neurotoxin ttx
and how this can be validated using the
integrated movie viewing tool
looking at the control well we can see
sustained neuronal activity
picrotoxin displays an increased
activity and connectivity
this is represented by the calcium
traces below each movie and
described by the mean correlation metric
neuronal activity is abolished by ttx as
expected
while both drugs showed a dramatic
effect in new journal activity face
images don't display any apparent
changes in the morphology of the
calculus
to obtain and increase biological
insight into your research systems
one can look at the effects that these
cell treat that these treatments have in
the bursting profile we can see where we
can
study the number of active nodes mean
correlation batch rate or intensity as
shown
in the backgrounds below
on the left hand side we can see the
profile of the baseline activity of our
untreated culture we can then compare
this baseline with effects of picrotoxin
treatment in the middle to understand
how these parts
have been modified with a similar number
of active nodes as controlled wells
the bars are more synchronized more
frequent and of higher intensity when
compared to vehicle
as expect from this stimulant those
lines represent the control values for
an easy comparison
in contrast ttx treatment almost
entirely stops activity in deco culture
this example shows the power that this
technology and its derived metrics can
potentially have to distinguish among
drug
drug treatments for the drug discovery
field for example or genetically
modified cells for disease modeling
another interesting example i wanted to
share with you is the capability of
using neuronal activity to compare the
functional phenotype of different
neuronal types
and so being able to characterize them
we have here ipsc derived cabinetic and
glutamatergic neurons from cdi
one can characterize them using the
previously described metrics
the data presented here allows to easily
see that non-excitatory cabinet neurons
on the left
exhibited a spontaneous activity but
only the excitatory glutamatergic
neurons such as coordinated network
activity one can imagine that this type
of sensitive characterization may enable
the investigation of disease versus
non-disease neurons
neurons from different brain regions or
even neurons primed with brain extracts
from
both healthy and disease patients
and the last example before we move on
to the final research area
and in order to illustrate the value of
neuronal activity module i wanted to
show you a model we developed to study
drug induced until
attenuation of network connectivity in
this example we studied the effects of
the chemotherapeutic drug taxon which is
given intravenously to cancer patients
unfortunately one of its side effects
includes neuropathy
we model this by treating a culture of
neurons with astrocytes with increasing
concentrations of taxon
from one picomola to one micromolar here
you have two representative videos of
the three minutes epoch
of a vehicle and taxes treated well you
can see the detrimental effects of the
drug update
then post treating the non-active orange
nodes represent the cells in which
calcium has leaked
and as they are not bursting the
software is not segmented them
as you can see with the plate view
visualization we had three replicates
per condition and here we have a summary
of the three minutes epoch of
all the treated wells at four different
time points
the first panel on the left shows the
summary calcium trace of all welfare
pre-treatment
for 10 days post infections we observe
that network had developed as the number
of active nodes have
plateaued i had plateaued and the
correlation was at least eighty percent
we then knew that it was time to treat
with taxon represented in the next three
panels you can see the three minute
calcium traces at
5 10 and 15 treatments
the ones we saw videos from before are
highlighted in orange
using this visualization one can clearly
see that the effect of taxol is
concentration dependent as expected
but also time-dependent in a chronic way
as you can only
start to detect the effects of taxol at
low concentrations
from day 10 or even 15 illustrating the
importance of long-term chronic studies
this effect could have been misused in a
short-term drug application
these data as mentioned before can be
concatenated and represented using time
courses under that concentration care
the time course on the left shows the
change in the number of active objects
with time
you can see the network is stabilizing
for 14 days before treatment was
performed
data was normalized to this
pre-treatment value allocating it 100
and deriving from me the percentage
change in the number of active objects
it's easy to visualize the concentration
and temporal dependent effect
the concentration curves in the middle
and the ic50 graph on the right hand
side confirms the temporal dependence of
this drug
showing how sensitive the neuronal
activity readout is
now one can think is this lack of
activity caused by taxol killing the
neurons
well in order to further elucidate the
effect of this drug we run a parallel
study this time using neurolite
instead of neuropathy reagent so to look
at the neuronal growth and to understand
the effects of taxol on morphology
rather than rather than on function the
bottom curve shows how taxable affects
neuronal lengths in a concentration and
temporal manner but with a slightly
different profile as the functional
effect
now in the top the table and its graph
show how at the top
three concentrations of taxol tested the
detrimental effect is fast within four
days
and the ic50 is for neuronal length and
activity compared
meaning that these top concentrations in
the nanomolar level are toxic enough to
affect both
morphology and function however as the
concentrations decrease you can see how
taxal effects function in a more
selective way
and the impact of morphology is much
smaller to the point that by day 10
neuronal activities affected 24 higher
than neuronal length
meaning that at these low concentrations
the neurites are still there but they're
just not communicating
this is one example on how by combining
different applications one can obtain
greater biological insight
so changing subjects we are now into the
last core application i'm going i wanted
to discuss today we are now into the
near immunology world
this slide shows you a cartoon and the
correlated image inside the image of an
effector cell in this case
human ipac microglia after maxwell
bioscience engulfing a target in this
case from the label apoptotic near 2a
we can see how the macroglia senses the
presence of the neuron approaches and
engulfs it
as we know the acidic environment of the
funguson derives into an increased
fluorescence which can be then imaged
and analyzed over time
enabling the quantification of
phagocytosis the protocol is a simple
fit of pre-level particles to the
microglia cultures with no ocean fixing
or lifting of the cell
in this video one can see one can see
the process in action and the graph on
the right shows a simple validation
indicating that the greater the number
of further label apoptotic neurons one
fits to this microglia
the greater the urine signal symbolizing
morphocytosis
so changing is likely the type of food
one can fit the macroglia
in this case and to test validity of the
system we aggregated a beta peptide and
further label it
we then fed it to different type of
cells bb2 mass microglia tnth human
glioblastoma or undifferentiated shs
human neuroglastoma
as you can see on the first graph and i
suspected only the microglial cell type
phagocytosis is peptide
we then tested how aggregation time
affected the uptake of a beta by bb2
microglia
and we found that the longer the peptide
was less aggregating up to four days
the higher the signal was we then moved
on to more precious hipsters microglia
from
actual bioscience and we observed a
concentration response in the uptake of
a beta by this effector cell
we tested the uptake of other
disease-related peptides by ipsc
macroglia to exemplify not only
alzheimer's disease with
a beta but also parkinson's disease with
alpha-synuclein
or ms using myelin-based protein in all
these cases there was microglia uptake
in a concentration-dependent manner
however and interestingly with different
uptake profiles
was taken up much faster than a beta or
alpha synoplane
and even three times higher
concentrations of alpha synoplane is
still yield only half the phagocytic
cytosis signal compared to the other two
peptides
the last slide to exemplify in my view
how these micro
microglial models can be used to study
the neurodegeneration
a last example on this front is how one
can use lifestyle analysis to gain
insight on a particular mechanism by
using differential pharmacology
as a tool here we can see a proposed
mechanism of phagocytosis of cells
published in the journal of cell science
by researchers from cambridge university
we wanted to discriminate between the
process of uptake of dead cells
etherocytosis versus the uptake of
smaller bioparticles
and understand whether integrins were
important in one or both mechanisms
for this purpose we fed bibitos within a
frodo label near two ways or e coli
particles respectively
and who applied an integrin inhibitor
selengite or a polymerization inhibitor
cytod cytode was expected to inhibit
both the uptake of dead cells and
bioparticles
as it stops any movement from the
microglia
and this is what we see here that cycle
inhibited both ephedra and phagocytosis
of bioparticles in a concentration
manner
selenite the integrin inhibitor we were
testing only blocked the ferrocytosis of
cells with no effect
on the phagocytosis of bioparticles you
can see however that the effect was only
partial suggesting that more mechanisms
are involved in this process
and to finish the fourth research area
i'd like to exemplify the use of our
chemotaxis assets to study the ability
of macroglia to migrate towards a stable
hematractin
this assay uses the clearview 96 wall
plates composed of a bottom reservoir
and a top insert containing a membrane
with 96 heavenly space 4
some depicted in blue
the other workflow is quite simple
firstly one coats the top membrane with
an ecm to enable cell movement and seep
the cells
treatments can be added at this stage
then the chemoattraction is added at
the bottom reservoir plate at different
concentrations and the insulin
containing the cells
is placed on top and lastly the plate is
image and analyzed to gather information
on how the microglia cells migrate
through the pores located within the
membrane
the inky side takes an image from the
top and the bottom of the membrane and
quantifies confluence
enabling the study of for instance bb2
microglia migration towards a c5 fake
hematractin
and finally as i look to the future i
wanted to touch on a promising area that
we are currently looking at
the synaptic pruning of neurons by
microglia
this video is formed from part of the
collaboration with science of
biotechnology
they show the great motility of the
human ipsc the giant microglia and how
actively they interact with the neurons
from primary cortex
an application that one can
automatically seize for example study
some plasticity
or the differential effects of microglia
pruning in disease and healthy
individuals
let's finish this talk by imaging how
much biological insight one could gain
from combining this pruning
with the previously seen applications
all right
so as a summary of this webinar and to
wrap up we've seen how lifestyle
analysis is
ideally suited to to develop and
validate cell models to answer
neuroscience questions
i've covered four general main areas of
interest neuronal cell health dynamics
activity and macroglial function we've
seen examples modeling neurotoxicity
neurodegeneration and neuroinflammation
and we've also briefly touched on how
one can gain
greater biological insight by combining
different applications and
pharmacological modulation
thank you very much for your attention i
really hope that you found this webinar
useful
you can find further information in the
links on your screen and you can view
and you will be receiving a follow-up
email with copies of this webinar
also we can discuss your thoughts during
the question session to follow